the phillies of course needing every win
they can get here down the stretch they
have 10 games left to play and at the
moment they're two and a half games
behind the atlanta braves in the
national league east as the braves lost
earlier today and they're facing arenola
who's making his 31st start of the year
an era of 4.48 and he's got a different
battery mate tonight for only the fourth
time this year
andrew knapp is doing the catching with
aaron out on the mound fastball strike
three called got him looking top of the
zone and wonder if he was looking for a
curveball probably most likely reynolds
looks back and played up our mark
carlson he said it was high but that was
a strike there you see overton's uh
numbers in just 11 innings not a lot
there and that's a good thing a lot of
zeros
and no unearned runs and no earned runs
but you can even go back uh seven
innings into this uh minor league run as
well without allowing one so it's been a
while and now it's bryce harper who's
been on quite a tear this ball bounced
knocked down by the first baseman moran
and he'll toss finally to overton
as overton scrambled over there and uh
moran waited for him just two steps from
the bag but toss to the pitch recovery
and the play goes
three one one two three for overton and
on to the second we go it's the pirates
nothing
and the philly's nothing
durant is bored with the first hit of
the game for pittsburgh lofted out to
left center field mccutcheon on the run
and he runs it down
good job by andrew mccutchen got the
jump on that one and made the play
you see alfred right there just goes
down and gets it it did just had just
that
just enough hang time for andrew to run
that thing down or else
you're looking at a big inning for the
buckos possibly that's his first walk
issued and it'll load the bases for
michael perez the pirates catcher
he got it with a change up second
strikeout for nola that's a big one with
the bases loaded and now two outs and
the pitcher connor overton is coming up
lifted in the air back at third oh this
might be trouble to freddie galvez can't
get it it drops it for a hit and two-run
score
holy cow it's the first major league at
bat
for connor overton and he bloops a
two-run single
right down the left-field line and the
pirates take the lead that had a hit
probability of 14 percent
here's key brian hayes and he hits this
hard to right field going back as harper
toward the wall looking up and clear the
deck
with a cannonball the other way for key
brian hayes
key brian hayes it's a three-run homer
oppo his sixth
and the pirates take a five-nothing lead
that is something else right there he
had two strikes on the opposing pitcher
who had never had a major league at bad
and he bloops one down the left field
line and now all of a sudden it's five
nothing pittsburgh ala moran got the
second inning started with a base hit
off aaron nola pirates are
playing their baseball version of
cornhole in the bullpen john there's a
game going on yeah i guess
that ball is crushed they better be
careful because it may be coming out
toward them and it is gone
off the facing of the second deck it's
six nothing pittsburgh
holland moran don't you know
hit that ball to county galway and the
pirates lead six to nothing you know i
say this often sometimes it just takes
one at back one swing
to kind of turn you around offensively
and it might have been that base hit
that he hit to center on a high fastball
that fastball was off the plate inside
and he hit it out the right center field
to the second deck and it's six to
nothing pittsburgh and aaron nola just
doesn't have it he does not didi
gregorius will lead off for the phillies
who trail in this one six to nothing not
the night the phillies were hoping for
that ball's a bullet deep to right field
it is gone
into the second deck dede gregorius this
12th home run and the phillies are on
the board
it's a 6-1 game
tremendous home run for dede gregorius
has the phillies get on the board with
didi's 12th of the season it's a 6-1
vogging
i would say there was no doubt about
that one
first
he gives up his first big league run
this year
[Music]
well he got his first big league rbi
before he gave up his first big league
run
as a pitcher and the phillies trying to
answer back and get back in this ball
game here they've got the heart of the
order coming up with two men in scoring
position and it's up high goes to the
back stop here comes nola he will score
off the mitt of perez but that pitch
very high
now
ground ball it's a three-run game swing
and a fly ball left center field
playable for reynolds tagging at third
is oh doable reynolds is going to throw
to the plate and oh doable slides in
safely it's a sacrifice fly it's a 6-3
game how big is it that they cut into
this lead
at least three runs at this point
utilities trail at six to three base hit
could get it even closer line drop down
to left field that's a fair ball going
to the corner harper's gonna cruise home
from second
mccutcheon goes to second base and rbi
double it's now a 6-4 game
it's a ball game again
here comes brad miller that run charged
to overton back toward the middle right
between the legs of ponce into center
field mccutcheon will
rumble home
it's a one-run game
third pinch hitter of the inning and
it's ronald torrez good numbers this
year with runners in scoring position
light drive out toward left field
alfred's going back it's over his head
and it bounces out of the yard
it's a three-run run for ronald teres
and for the fourth time this year the
phillies have erased at least a six-run
deficit
they've taken the lead it's eight to six
here at the bottom of the sixth hitting
strikeout and then the walk rio muto is
coming up swung on hit in the air right
field deep going back onto go at the
wall look it up it's gone
opposite field
two-run homer for jt rebutto
ten on the board for the phils they lead
it 10-6 here in the bottom of the
seventh and it'll face two three and
four in the order topper back over the
mound
dede flags it down throws on the run and
time what a play
that's maybe as much range as we've seen
from dede all season really that was a
terrific play wasn't hit hard which gave
him a chance to get up the middle
but a long ways to go feel it and maybe
even on the second base side of the bag
i didn't think he had a chance to get
there jt will be the batter here with
the bases loaded he's had a big game a
game he didn't even start he swings and
lines it up the middle there's a base
hit one run will score here comes segura
around third the throw to the plate is
late jt off the benches three for three
with four reveals
one more out for
another
improbable win
popped up jankowski says he has it he
does it's another improbable victory for
the phils they move within two games of
the atlanta braves in the national
league east